now i want to pose this question to you
i wonder if you remember
when we first learned what matrices were
right we
drew an analogy
and we worked with matrices as if they
represented do you remember what we
started with what the very first things
we were like matrices are basically
another way to say
simultaneous equations very good right
so if you have a system
of linear equations
you can represent it using a matrix okay
but a matrix is just it's just numbers
right um so
they don't have to just represent
systems of linear equations right let me
give you an example
when we were talking about
the basic building block of mats right
do you remember what the basic building
block was
we said there were sets right so if you
wanted to count things right you're like
look um three
three is the thing that is in common
between a set of of whiteboard markers
right
like this it has a quality about it it
has
three nurse right has that attribute
okay but then this idea of three
is much bigger than just counting right
we started to apply it to other things
we started to apply it to measurement or
to debts or direction and so you can
have things like
minus three
even though you can't have minus three
whiteboard markers or we can have things
like the square root of three even
though you can't have the square root of
three wiper markers right so an idea
starts somewhere
it starts somewhere but then you can
take it further than that that's one of
the hallmarks of mathematics stuff like
trig right trig starts with triangles
and then it goes off and becomes weird
stuff like this and you're like where's
the triangle in that and the answer is
well it's hiding in there somewhere
right and this kind of thing happens
everywhere in nature where repeating
patterns happens so an id it starts in
one place and then it goes
so the idea where i want to take you
today
are things called vectors okay now
vectors are a very very general idea
essentially all they're about is about a
direction okay
and so i want us to give an example of a
matrix right and then start to work with
it and then work out what a determinant
is that's how that's out in time
so here's a matrix
okay here's my example matrix and i've
got four numbers there okay so this
could represent a system of linear well
in this case it'll be expressions it's
not augmented so it could be something
like for instance um this could
represent a x plus b y
uh and c x plus d y there you go there's
my system and it's linear no problem
but instead of that today i'm going to
think about what if i took the same
matrix
and use them to represent vectors so
draw with me a set of axes
we'll only need the first quadrant like
so
okay
that's his amx here so i was just giving
an example of one way
that you could interpret this matrix and
i'm going to give you another way
so instead of thinking of the a and the
b and the c and the d as coefficients
i want to think of them as coordinates
as values so for instance maybe a and b
could be like
an x direction and a y direction so for
instance
a b this first row here i'm going to use
it to represent
this vector okay so i've started from
the origin
okay and i'm going off in a direction
that i'm in two dimensions so that's why
i've got
two things that will describe
which way i'm going okay
so where is this thing if i had to give
its coordinates because we're familiar
with coordinates it would be a
b
right a in this direction and b in that
direction and their total is a vector
that way okay
and just for the sake of interest let's
put this second vector let's have it
going up this way so something like this
another victor vector victim
no other kinds of piece of information
here so again it's going to have
coordinates c
d
now what starts to get interesting
is if you then add some of these vectors
together for instance
if you did this first vector down here
if you take this first vector up here
right this a b vector which goes off in
this direction
and if you add it
to the other vector right
so it would be like going all the way up
to here
and then going well okay i guess it will
be a line parallel and it will be the
same distance okay so something like
this i'll try my best
there you go
so
this point up here represents this
vector plus this vector and there's my
destination okay
now just a quick thought right what if i
did the vectors in the other direction
what if i added them in reverse what if
i did this one
and then the other one where would i end
up
in the same spot good it would end up in
center you can kind of see it can't you
right and the reason why is because as
with most things addition
addition is what's the word for it when
you can do it in any order we've been
thinking about this right
yeah very good commutative communicative
i actually have no idea how that's
pronounced so you can
go this vector than that one you'll end
up here or the other way now
question one
what are the coordinates
of this point
what are its coordinates you can almost
see them
can't you
hmm
well well firstly for instance let's
think about this um this horizontal
blade that's that's a isn't it right and
then you've gone a bit further how much
further have you gone
and the answer is yeah this is this
horizontal part right so it'll be a four
okay
in the same way you can read out the
vertical total distance right it's going
to be b first and then d or vice versa
doesn't matter because addition is
commutative okay
all right so there was my first question
what were the coordinates here's my
second question what's the um
what's the area of this thing
if you could express
this area in here this parallelogram
in terms of you've got one two three
four numbers four numbers that you can
express it in terms of i'm gonna let you
actually have a think have a go at it
see if you can boil it down to something
as simple as possible what's the area if
you think you have an answer call me
over